[Music]
the once upon a time series finale it's
so crazy to say that how are you feeling
tonight
I mean it's it is crazy to say that to
hear it I feel great I feel like we've
done such a great job over the last
seven years telling these stories you
know everything has to come to an end at
some point it's it's bittersweet my
heart breaks but I also am so proud of
what we've done and I will miss everyone
I'm sure I will see them again but you
know thank thank God for DVDs right
because you can go back and keep
watching them at flicks yeah Netflix
whole shebang
we started off in once upon a time
following what happens if the Evil Queen
gets her happy ending we've been with
you on this journey all these ups and
downs twists and turns spells broken
curses we'll Regina get her happy
endings
it's like the biggest question the seven
years will she ever be happy yes I
believe she will be it will be you know
I don't want to spoil anything but I
think Regina has been happy for quite
some time I think in the seventh season
the curse made heard Ronny and she
wasn't as happy she felt unfulfilled
that character but when she woke up well
obviously there was a lot going on so
she had to go into hero action mode but
I think internally she is quite content
and very happy but something does happen
in the finale that I think will really
please the audience and I
I hope you all love it as much as I love
Rodina and what she ends up getting in
the series mantle I think you'll really
enjoy you read that two-hour series
finale what was your initial reaction
and what should the fans be prepared for
I cried throughout the entire thing like
just reading it my heart was just
breaking throughout the whole thing and
there's so much that happens it is once
upon a time so if there's you know it's
it's fun-filled it's it's touching it's
emotional it's heartbreaking in moments
you will cry so just make sure you have
a box of tissues nearby
and lastly fans loved with friendships
it evolved between Regina and Emma
throughout this series did you get to
share any scenes with Jennifer Morrison
in this final episode in the finale
possibly